I'm Alec Ross senior advisor for
innovation in the office of the
secretary of state
you know from the earliest days of
American diplomacy dating back to the
18th century it would take weeks for a
single piece of Correspondence to move
from one continent to another in the
days of Benjamin Franklin and Thomas
Jefferson being our ambassadors to
France they would work and they would
send correspondence back and by the time
they got a some feedback it was
literally a month later that pattern
largely held arm until in the
introduction of telephony which of
course of the Telegraph and telephony
which then shrunk dramatically the the
amount of time that it took to
communicate and that then held until ten
years ago when when the internet became
the powerful tool that it is today so
really I think the major shifts in
diplomacy um dating back to the 18th
century reflect the major shifts in
communications technology and so 50
years ago I think that there was very
little different between how we
conducted our diplomacy and how we did
it in the 18th century you more often
than not was was white guys with white
shirts and red ties sitting over
mahogany table sipping cups of coffee
talking to somebody who looked just like
that across the other side of the table
one thing that 21st century statecraft
is doing now is it's changing that
engagement from being exclusively
government to government but also
allowing us now to engage government to
people in people to people and so the
changes in statecraft don't often happen
that often and and and it's only very
very recently that the very unsettling
settle technology-driven changes in in
diplomacy or taking place
first that the use of social media at
the State Department and in the federal
government is very very new you know
it's no surprise to anybody that that
social media was an important part of
Barack Obama becoming president and
after he became president part of what
he brought with him was the value of
technology as a way to connect people
who are traditionally disconnected from
Washington from the policy-making arena
and so what we're doing right now is
we're introducing social media both
broadly meaning the White House and the
State Department using it as sort of a
big blunt instrument to engage with the
people of the world around big events
like the president going to Cairo or
something like that but what's actually
every bit is compelling to me is what
we're doing on a far more local basis so
that our embassy in Lesotho for example
can use social media in Lesotho to
engage the people there and create a
smaller community of engagement a more
specialized community of engagement and
some conversations that are more organic
that are more reflective of what the
real local interests and concerns are so
social media has this two contrasting
possibilities on the one hand it can
help us engage much larger numbers of
people than we have traditionally so our
audience really are the six billion
people on the planet but on the other
hand it allows us to engage people much
more locally and much more organically
than perhaps we'd ever done when our
communications were driven exclusively
out of embassy in company capitals only
dealing with government officials
this is this is amazing let me let me
talk a little bit about the most recent
one which was in Ghana one of the things
that we did was our embassy in South
Africa created a partnership with a
mobile based social networking company
through which we solicited questions for
the president and comments to get to the
White House immediately in advance of
the speech two hundred thousand
questions and comments came in through
this mobile based social network you
know in advance of the the Ghana speech
which is which is absolutely spectacular
and what we then did is the president
then answered questions that African
journalists um that african journal is
selected they were dubbed and translated
into a handful of languages and podcast
and and a couple more examples from the
ghana speech because it gets me very
excited one of the things that we did is
a lot of people get their information
through SMS and africa so one thing we
did is we promoted this speech through
SMS and then we then we would actually
take portions of the speech and push
them out via SMS networks and this is
another case of how the consumption of
media arm differs from one culture to
another so i personally i don't actually
don't want to get text messages of
somebody's speech you know to me that
wouldn't necessarily be particularly
compelling but on the African continent
what we found is at that point in fact
this is how a lot of people get their
media and so we took advantage of of
understanding how people access to media
and access to information there and we
made good use of it so and then lastly a
lot of what we did is we partnered with
Africa based social media and said all
right you know how can we
leverage the President's speech to reach
the audiences that you have captured
here you know what is it about this
that's most interesting to you and then
we worked with them and what it did is
it took a speech that normally would
have been a quote-unquote speech to
Ghana or to the Ghanaian people and it
turned into a continent continent wide
phenomenon where we estimate that more
than 40 million people actually heard
the speech
smart what smart power really is is it's
using all of the mean all of all of the
means to engage possible so hard power
is military power and a lot of what we
saw during the Bush administration was
the United States leading with its
military and there are times where it's
appropriate to do so you know what Osama
bin Laden and al-qaeda did merited a
military response in Afghanistan however
what we can't always do is just say all
right if we have a problem abroad let's
call the Defense Department that can't
be the way the only way in which we
engage the wider world and so what smart
power is is it saying all right let's
think proactively about the world around
us and let's think about what tools we
have our at our disposal yes there's
defense but there's also diplomacy
there's development and we don't need to
just engage government-to-government one
of the things that I think Hillary
Clinton did that was so compelling and
her last trip to India was when she went
to Mumbai whose through it was is three
days before she went and saw the Prime
Minister say yes she valued being able
to engage with the Indian government and
the work that she and the State
Department did with the Indian
government was very important but so too
was the outreach that she did to indian
entrepreneurs so too was the outreach
that she did to the indian NGO sector so
smart power means that we are not just
engaging government to government over
that proverbial mahogany table with the
flags in the background but we're also
engaging in other countries academics
it's entrepreneurs and it's civil
society sector
that's a that's a great question you
know prior to coming to this state
department I spent the last 10 years of
my life working to bridge the digital
divide you know I like everybody else in
the mid and late 90s was witnessing this
technology driven change in the way that
we communicated in transacted business
and and a handful of friends of mine and
I in two thousand started a nonprofit
called one economy the purpose of which
was to connect people around the globe
to these technologies and and we went
from hip for guys in a basement actually
being the world's largest digital divide
organization and one of the things that
I've seen over the last ten years and
again this is working in the nonprofit
sector this is not working in government
is there is a very very fast adoption of
these technologies around the globe is
it everywhere no but it's increasingly
universal one of the things that one of
the what are the one of the important
points that people need to bear in mind
is that the way that people actually
access the network in the developing
world might be different than the way
people in the United States are
accessing the network of the six built
there are six billion people on the
planet but there are also four billion
mobile phones so we can already see
right now in the developing world people
are skipping sort of the desktop as the
way in which they access the network and
they're accessing it directly on their
handhelds one of the places where I'm
doing a lot of work right now is in the
Democratic Republic of Congo which is
one of the the poorest places on earth
and and one of the things that that the
State Department is hoping to do there
is use telecommunications and use
technology tools as a way of protecting
women particularly in eastern Congo who
are vulnerable to
acts of extreme violence of rape and in
examining the feasibility of this you
know I said oh you know it sounds great
but you know is that naive you know
number one is there can people use cell
phones are they using them what about
literacy gaps and one of the things that
I learned was that today at this moment
fifty percent of the country and it is a
massive country with a land mass equal
to Texas in Alaska combined fifty
percent of the country right now is
covered by a wireless signal and 14 out
of every 100 people in the Congo are
already mobile phone subscribers and one
of the things that's different in the
Congo that's different in the United
States is in the United States everybody
has their own phone but in the Congo
it's normal actually for three or four
people to share the same phone and so if
you just do the math all right today 14
out of every 100 people or mobile phone
subscribers if you assume that there are
three users per phone what that means is
that today without the United States
doing a thing forty-two percent of the
country are re on mobile phones so in
one of the poorest regions of the earth
the Congo we already see that half of
the people are connecting to the network
and so that for me is is great
affirmation that we should be pushing
these technologies into the developing
world and further we should be thinking
about how 21st century technology can
help solve some of our most intractable
development challenges and will there be
places where we go where people simply
aren't using cell phones where there's
no mobile coverage where the literacy
level is such that people just can't
figure it out sure but I think that
instead of just waiting for the world to
catch up the United States can play a
role in helping to lead and so in
looking at the Congo again um fifty
percent of the country is covered today
a study that I saw by goldman sachs said
that by 2013 eighty-eight percent of the
country will be covered so part of it
makes sense to me for us to engage now
while sort of the whole world is getting
onto these technologies and figuring out
now how we can use these technologies
for economic and social good
I think that there is a lot of
unintended paternalism when people think
about technology we oftentimes assume
that people who are low-income or people
who are racial minorities are somehow
not going to understand technology and
that we need to sort of parse out giving
access to technology to people who are
low-income people who are who are racial
minorities and I think that I think that
that that that is just completely
contradictory to what actually all the
data and evidence show which is that it
doesn't matter how much money is in your
wallet it doesn't matter from whence you
come young people all around the globe
right now have this incredibly intuitive
understanding of Technology and of its
power and so introducing technology into
poor communities doesn't need to be done
so paternalistic Lee because guess what
within a couple days this 15 year old is
going to be way ahead of you and so
that's one thing that I that that is
very important to me is to take some of
the paternalism that I think lives in a
lot of our development practices and
recognize that when it comes to
introducing technology when it comes to
develop to introducing innovation into
poor communities don't be too arrogant
about it because the folks there are
going to be a lot quicker with it a lot
smarter about it than you in very short
order
think that I think there are a number of
examples one of the problems
particularly in the developing world is
the lack of medical workers arm so you
know you go into places of extreme
poverty with enormous prevalence of arm
of disease and you've got one or two
healthcare workers literally trying to
steward the medical interests of
thousands of patients in need so one way
in which technology can play a good role
beyond just giving alerts you know it's
twelve o'clock it's time to take the
green pill another way is to actually
push in preventative in for preventative
information to people so one of the
examples that I've seen that's very very
compelling is for pregnant women and
pushing content to them by SM by SMS
about what are those things that can be
done to ensure the health of fetus to
ensure a healthy pregnancy the thing
that I think is more exciting though
I've talked about push technology what I
think is more interesting and compelling
than that even is being able to create
some exchange so right now if there is a
sorghum farmer in Mali and that sorghum
farmer has lost fifty percent of his
crop and he doesn't know why right now
the way in which we would provide aid to
that farmer is some professor in Surrey
goes to goes to the airport in London
flies to Lagos flies to Molly gets in a
Jeep drives for three hours looks at the
crop and says oh this is what you've got
today there's no reason why that farmer
shouldn't be able to take a video
enabled phone or a photo enabled phone
take up dozen pictures of the crop um
send those you know send those beauty
over mobile network send those over
there by email to the professor in
Surrey and rather than the three
airplane fight two flights in the three
hour jeepers
I in the five thousand dollars in
expenses that person can say oh this is
the problem this is what you do oh and
by the way in the meantime you've saved
two weeks and you know another third of
the the farmers crop so a lot of what
I'm interested in doing is figuring out
how experts can connect to the
agricultural world can connect to
entrepreneurs and provide real-time
technical assistance that's exchange
rather than just pushing things and
rather than people having to physically
be there but create some virtual
connections between people
absolutely look it would be completely
naive of me to say oh here's the
internet here's 21st century
technologies kumbaya democracy wins
that's that's not realistic that's not
the world that we're living in I do
believe that access to technology
provides people with information that
they otherwise wouldn't be getting I
think that that expands their worldview
I think the young people growing up in
Gaza today who are being who can access
the internet and can get information
other than what they might be hearing
from the mullah do I think that that is
like that that is in America's foreign
policy interests absolutely all of that
said America's enemies al Qaeda those
those entities that want to destroy us
are sophisticated in their own use of
technology and we're and and they know
how to use it for communication they
know how to use it for recruitment I
mean you can go on the internet right
now and in Google a handful of terms and
you can in terms you can see these these
recruitment websites we've seen them do
horrible things on the Internet um you
know where they will where they will
exploit armed people who they've
captured in who their who they're
they're torturing or killing so this
technology offers a universe of
resources to everybody and that doesn't
just necessarily mean the good guys and
that we all live happily ever after do I
think that this is a powerful tool for
social good for economic good and for
democracy absolutely but it would be
naive of me and naive of anybody to
simply say oh well you know we can use
this they want and this is that you know
we will win the war for people's minds
and hearts you know without any push
back up by by virtue of the power of
these networks
I do not think large campaigns will ever
be the same there were some absolute
rock stars on the Obama campaign
cheuvreux sparse and Macon Phillips and
Chris Hughes and what one thing that was
very interesting about the Obama
campaign was those people who are really
running the campaign people like David
ploughin and David Axelrod they
empowered these young entrepreneurs on
the campaign to run wild with technology
and to really test the boundaries of
what it could do and you know I'll give
one example of something that at the
time I don't know if people quite
understood how significant it would be
but it turned out to be significant when
the campaign decided to announce its
vice presidential pick of Vice President
Biden by text message and people could
send in their cell phone numbers and get
the alert by text message one of the
things that was amazing about that was
because so many people uh subscribe to
that because so many people wanted the
text message alert we suddenly now are
able to capture the cell phone numbers
of huge numbers of Americans which
enabled us then to have ongoing
communications with them I think that a
lot of what the Obama campaign pioneered
in terms of its in terms of its use of
technology is just going to have to
become a standard part of every national
campaign by both parties from now on and
I think that a lot of it will devolve to
to congressional and gubernatorial races
because some of what we saw I might have
this number wrong but I think that Joe
roast bars had a 190 person staff one of
the things that we know about technology
is that it becomes increasingly
commoditized and increasingly
inexpensive so things that may have cost
the Obama campaign millions of dollars
some entrepreneurs out there figuring
out how to do it for hundreds of
thousands of dollars and how to sell it
so i have a feeling every candidate for
governor every candidate for the
Senate and for the house is saying hey
how can I get some of that Obama
campaign tech mojo
couldn't tell you how I prepared for
this you know I never thought of my I
still don't consider myself to be a
technologist per se you know I i I've
spent the last 15 years fighting poverty
you know I got started as an inner-city
schoolteacher and West Baltimore
teaching middle schoolers and you know I
went and I did affordable housing work
and then I started a nonprofit that was
focused on technology but for me it
wasn't about technology it was about
educational and economic opportunity and
what I did is I sort of immersed myself
in technology as a way of addressing
those issues now if somebody said to me
today you know Alec you're 37 years old
you doing something that's really cool
that fuses technology with diplomacy and
development that's something I'd like to
do how do I get those technology chops
how do I get ahead of the curve on these
things my advice to that person would
actually be don't go get a job in the
technology sector get a job in the
development world um but figure out how
you can apply technology in that world